the vision of kids is rapidly growing
when they are young and once they reach
six it's completely developed however
one in five children have a vision
disorder because children don't know
better to them their vision seems normal
where one kid season eight the other
might see a three too often teachers and
adults also don't know the signs of a
child's impaired sight and wrongly label
them as slow or learning disabled that's
why all kids should have a professional
I check every one to two years if that
cannot be provided it's important for
parents and teachers to learn how to
detect a condition here are some signs
to spot eye problems a student asks to
change seats from back to front they
look into their peers notebook instead
of the board they squint their eyes to
focus on objects in the distance they
look at things really close up they
execute handiwork poorly and their
handwriting is extraordinarily bad
sometimes kids even walk clumsily or
show some more explicit symptoms like
tearing or itching of the eyes to
perform a simple eye test have your
students close one eye and read out loud
a standard tumbling each art from six
meters away school children age 6 or
above should be able to read all lines
including the one labeled 2030 then
repeat it with the other eye when they
do the test observe the students posture
and behavior they shouldn't have to move
or tilt their head turn their eyes or
constantly blink just to read the chart
if you identify a child with an eye
problem please inform the parents and if
available the school's doctor or
principal it's important to care early
and to help kids learn and live better
and to prevent further eye diseases
after the kid has received proper care
by an eye specialist you might see a
massive study improvement
see below the link to download a basic
tumbling each art which can be printed
with an ordinary a4 black and white
printer as always we are looking forward
to receive your feedback in the comment
section below
please also subscribe to our YouTube
channel and like us on Facebook thank
you for watching